[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
This is Bruno Aziza.
And welcome to another
edition of "Data Journeys."
This is where you come
to learn from leaders
in data and
analytics, people that
have had amazing growth,
incredible results, who tell us
about their journey--
also, what we need to do and
what we need to avoid doing.
Today, I've got the honor to
be here with Joe from Telus.
Joe, thank you so much
for taking the time
to talk to us today.
Tell us a little
bit about Telus.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Perfect.
Thanks for having me, Bruno.
So I work at Telus.
Telus is the third-largest
telecommunications company
in Canada.
We represent wireless,
wireline systems.
We also have some
interesting divisions
in health, agriculture, and IoT.
Our wireless division
represents nine and 1/2 million
subscribers across Canada.
So that's a fairly large sample
of people within the country
of 36 million.
And my group, specifically,
is Telus Insights.
Our division was
founded in 2015.
And we're really focused on
trying to commercialize data
in a privacy-preserving manner.
So that means taking data
that we have as a company
and bringing it out
to market in a way
that the privacy of the
individuals or the devices
that the data comes from isn't
being impacted negatively
by anything we do.
And everything is
looking at aggregates.
We really see this as
a market differentiator
compared to other
data monetization
groups at other companies.
And we've seen this lead
to a lot of the success
with our product to date.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's
excellent-- so how
to monetize data
in a secure manner.
You also have amazing scale.
Tell us a little
about the volume
of data that you're dealing
with and the types of inputs
that you're getting.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Yeah.
So our primary data
set we focus on
is our wireless
subscriber location--
so it's location coming
off of our network.
We get network events
any time a cell phone
talks to the network.
So it sends a signal when
it makes phone calls, text
message, as it migrates
between towers,
or anytime it's been inactive
for about 30 minutes or so.
And so with that, we're building
about 74 billion location
records every month.
And we have about 275,000 unique
points of interest on the map
that we split up into about
5,000 different unique
polygons.
And that number of
polygons continues
to grow month over month as more
users start using our system
and upload their own
custom areas to look at.
And this is the
result [INAUDIBLE]
analyzing over 1.2
petabytes of data this year.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's
quite incredible.
So the products
involved here are
BigQuery, of course,
Dataflow, Pub/Sub, Composer,
and a whole host
of other products.
You also analyze
data in Data Studio.
Tell us a little bit
about the first use case
here that you've been
primarily involved in,
is the data for good use case.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Yeah.
So when the pandemic hit
in mid-March in Canada,
we said as an
organization, there's
something we need
to do about this.
And we need to provide
data out in a way that
reiterates our stance in
the market towards privacy,
so really focuses on what we
can and can't do with data,
but also gives access to
that data to government
organizations and
researchers who
have a real need and a
desire to use data to inform
their decision making and help
them make the right decisions
at the right time.
So we opened up to this concept.
Our CEO signed off on it.
Our chief privacy officer--
chief data and trust officer,
I should say-- was really
backing this and supporting it.
And so we've managed
to, in three weeks,
roll out a new
platform on top of GCP
that really allowed
us to provide
these insights and information
to our government customers.
We signed up 26
customers-- or 27, now--
since the pandemic started and
have been able to provide them
with information that
can help them understand
mobility patterns, what
communities are interconnected,
what health regions are
interconnected, how far are
people traveling
on an average day,
how well are people
receiving public health
messaging, and doing all of
this with large aggregate data
samples so that nothing's
about individuals.
It's all about communities
and how communities are
interacting with each other.
And this has resulted in
some really positive effects
for various health groups
across the country, which is
something we're very proud of.
And from doing this, we
actually won the HPE-IAPP 2020
Innovation in Privacy award.
So that's a very
big deal for us,
and we're very excited
to have won that.
It really shows that
privacy differentiator
is core to our product and
really core to what we do.
And it's really helped
us gain traction
with these government agencies.
BRUNO AZIZA: Well, first
of all, congratulations.
And then it's amazing.
Thank you for doing
this for the community.
You're providing a great
service to everyone.
Now, you have been at
Telus for nine years,
and you've had a
ton of experiences.
I want to step back and
take a look at, overall,
why did you choose
Google, and what
has been the improvement
you've seen compared
to, maybe, on-prem systems?
And then we're going to go
into the dos and the don'ts.
But first, why Google for you?
JOE BETTRIDGE: Yeah.
So before Google, we were trying
to analyze this data using
an on-premise Hadoop cluster.
What it was-- it tried
to be powerful enough.
We continued to
expand that cluster.
It was getting very
costly to do so.
We were seeing results--
to understand something like,
maybe, a tourism region's
visitorship was taking
us about a month
to produce a month
worth of information.
So we were running
at that bleeding edge
where, if we got
one more data point,
we wouldn't hit our
deadlines for customers.
So we were getting in this
very concerned mode of working,
where it wasn't right.
And we knew there was
something better out there.
So we started researching
what different things were
out there.
And we came across BigQuery.
And BigQuery had a lot of
benefits towards GIS data
specifically.
So all of this location
data-- a lot of the analysis
and a lot of the
complex analytics
really require standard
geography libraries.
And so what Google has
put into BigQuery there
for standard geography was a
really strong differentiator
for us.
And then the general support
we saw from the Google teams--
so when we engaged Google, they
were very good about providing
specialists who would help us
with architecture, who would
help our teams, give us
training, really get us up
to speed and comfortable.
And finally, the fact that
BigQuery runs off of ANSI SQL
meant that a lot of the
stuff we'd built in the past
could be ripped out of the
system it was in and placed up
into the cloud quite quickly
and quite successfully.
And we saw that when we first
migrated, about a year ago,
a large chunk of our data.
And we were able to move some
of our algorithms within days
and got some very fast results.
I think we had a
25-times speed increase.
So what was taking a month
was taking a day to run.
So it's a significant difference
in just that caliber of result.
And with that, we're also
able to really, really,
truly use our human capital
as well as possible.
So part of what we're
running is consulting.
And you ideally want to reduce
the number of man hours taken
because, when I'm sending to
pay a data scientist to watch
a circle spin on their screen
while Hadoop's chugging away
at a result, I'm still
paying for their time
whether or not that
result's coming through.
And so BigQuery
has also allowed us
to do more with a small team.
And we couldn't
have done the things
we've done around COVID
without the technology there.
BRUNO AZIZA: We hear this a lot
from customers, is typically,
big data yields
to big questions.
But the ability to go
through the cycle faster
enables you to ask bigger
questions but also maybe better
questions and maybe
more questions.
So it invites people
to innovate faster
without having to worry so much
about the operational aspect
of it.
Now, you have learned a ton
through your experience.
And I want to know--
first, let's start
with the positive
side of the equation.
As you're learning what it means
to become data-driven and be
modernized in the
cloud, what are
some of the, maybe, two,
three best practices
you've learned in this process?
JOE BETTRIDGE: I
think the number one
best practice is to keep
on top of what's happening.
You guys are launching
new tools and new ways
of looking at data,
new pieces, constantly.
And the rollout is quick.
There's new stuff happening.
And keeping on top of that can
really save you a lot of time.
We found that
sometimes it's faster
to come to the Google
product team and say,
hey, we really want
to be able to do X.
And oftentimes, you guys
are already working on that
and can give us a
date when it's ready.
So it's faster than us building
it from scratch ourselves
and then having to replace
it a few months later.
So really, keeping on
top of update logs,
being involved in
community forums,
understanding what's
happening with the product
and how it's evolving--
that's a really big
do and has saved us a lot of
headaches and a lot of time.
Getting close to the
Google team kind of rolls
into that-- but understanding
what the product team's doing,
being close to
your sales agents,
understanding what
they're providing
and what they can help with.
The team has been
incredibly supportive.
It's been one of the better
experiences we've had.
I've been in the software
industry for about 10 years
now, and I would say
it's second to none
in terms of the quality
of service we've received.
So really, really
happy with that.
And I think the
closer you can get
with the people you're
working with from Google,
the more you can gain from that.
You guys are experts in your
platforms and your tools.
And you're willing to
share that expertise.
And you're very good at
sharing that expertise
in a very genuine way that helps
us move forward as a business.
We've been really
happy with that.
And the third one's
something that I think
is true for any data
science team, regardless
of where you're working.
But give people the
opportunity to experiment.
Things don't always work
the same in BigQuery
as traditional
database technologies.
Things don't always do
what you want them to do.
You really want to give
your people enough time
to experiment and play and
do R&D work if you really
want to see the true
success and drive
those really big measures.
If you don't give
people time to explore,
they won't flourish as
much as they really can
with these technologies.
There's a bit of
a paradigm shift
in terms of the
thinking of how you have
to look at data in BigQuery
and how you want to query it,
how you want to look at it.
And giving people time to
understand that, play with it,
and experiment can really lead
to some astonishing results.
It can really improve how
you're working with it.
As much as things are ANSI SQL,
and you can rip and replace,
you can do significantly
better if you
take the time to look
at how to optimize
and how to play around with it.
BRUNO AZIZA: Thank
you for the feedback.
We're happy that you're happy.
And it's true-- if
you're in the community,
we have roles dedicated
to your success,
from our customer engineers
through our developer relations
team.
And we have people
really focused
on making sure
you're successful.
I'm assuming you're also reading
newsletters and other forums.
But what's your favorite forum?
I'm curious.
JOE BETTRIDGE: So Chad
from your GIS group
has a community
forum on Google Chat.
He set up a really
great forum there
that has a lot of the leading
people in the community--
and being able to see what
people are posting about,
see messaging, really
get on top of that.
And the other thing is
the sales engineers--
we have a lot of
meetings with them
to regularly keep up to date on
what products are coming out,
what's new and exciting.
And I find both of
those are the best
ways of getting information
for me because they're
very knowledgeable
on the product,
more so than what I've seen from
most sales engineering groups.
They really know what's
coming up and what it will do.
And they also taken the time
to understand our problems
and know where
we're coming from.
So they know if a product's
a good fit for us.
And they're often very
on top of saying, hey, we
have this new thing launching.
You should check it out.
And they know who to
go to within our team.
So they've been really,
really good to work with.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's
great to hear.
And yeah, this community
you're talking about
is what we call the DACC,
the Data Analytics Customer
Council, which is a
meeting that we have.
We used to have
this once a year,
but now we have
this every month.
So it gives you
more opportunities
to connect with our roadmap
and our developer organization,
engineering organization.
And then, of course,
there is a group
where you don't have to
wait for the meeting.
You can interact
with us directly
and the rest of the community.
That's what it means to be
part of the data analytics
community at Google.
So now, that was
for the positive.
Let's talk about some
of the worse practices,
some of, maybe, the
mistakes that you've
learned along the way that
you would tell someone getting
started today to
try to avoid them.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Yeah.
The number one mistake
is, know what data
you have duplicated where,
how things are set up
in terms of retention policies.
We made a stupid mistake
of, one of our teams
had accidentally set a default
to retain data for three years
after deletion.
So we thought we
were deleting data.
And we're watching our
bills go up and up and up
and couldn't figure it out.
We reached out.
We submitted support tickets.
And someone from Google
realized what was going on
and corrected it for us.
But it really taught
us a big lesson about,
cloud expenses can go way up.
I mean, relative to the
human capital costs, again,
that we were seen before
on our old infrastructure,
this just pales in comparison.
We really didn't pay nearly
as much for these mistakes
as we were paying to have
people sit at a computer.
So it was a good
lesson to learn.
But I would suggest people
are careful with things
like retention policies.
Make sure you have the right
data in the right environments.
Don't overreplicate your
data if you don't need to.
Use things like views
to allow data to be
accessed across environments.
Use the tools that are
there to be successful.
It's not traditional
database management.
You have to treat it a
little bit differently.
So that would be
my number one one
because that has some
cost associated with it.
And it rolls into
my second one, which
is, really, don't be
afraid to fail at this.
Things are going to go wrong.
But you'll be able
to crack them.
You'll be able to
stand it back up.
Again, we launched
a major product
in three weeks that was
meeting a very serious need
in the market for
data around COVID.
It's not something we could have
done on our old infrastructure.
A lot of us spent some very late
nights in those three weeks,
getting that up and running.
It was probably closer to six
to eight weeks of actual work.
But still, it's
something that can
be done with this kind
of tool behind you.
And you can't do that on
traditional, on-prem things.
Just ordering hardware
alone would take you
longer than that.
So really, the power is there.
It just needs to be utilized.
And you have to be not afraid
to take that first step.
And I think a lot of
people are afraid to take
that first step because
they might get it wrong.
And it's not a big deal because
things are moving faster.
You get something wrong--
you can course
correct much easier
than you could in traditional
hardware-type database
development.
So the other one is, don't
expect this to magically fix
everything.
I think some of our
team, especially
at our executive level, were
expecting, you go to the cloud,
and suddenly, there's
no more problems.
Everything's better-- brush your
hands, walk away kind of thing.
And it's really not that.
This will fix some
of your problems.
It will introduce
some new problems.
You still need
the support teams.
You still need the
infrastructure people there.
Security development
still needs to be there.
Their roles might
shift slightly in what
they're doing versus managing
services versus managing
hardware.
But they're still needed, and
they're still a necessary part
of those teams.
You're not going to save
costs on those kind of things.
But where you will save costs
are on the actual people
doing the work.
And you'll be able to do more
work with less people, which
is really a bigger benefit.
But don't expect just suddenly
to be one data scientist
spinning up an
entire environment,
fixing everything and solving
all the problems for you.
You're going to need teams to
support these kind of things.
And that's something
that's just necessary,
regardless of where you go.
BRUNO AZIZA: That's great.
You gave us a lot
to think about.
I mean, there's a lot here.
It's a very rich interview.
Thanks for giving
us the time today.
I have two things I think
I want to highlight--
this first aspect of staying
in touch with the Google team,
either through the
field resources you have
for your account or the
many opportunities--
forums and newsletters
and groups--
that we have created for you.
I really want to
encourage everyone
to do that if you're part
of the community today.
And then the second
aspect you touched
on on financial governance-- you
have to watch out for how you
set up your system, of course.
But the good news here
is, because you're
in the cloud, it's more than
just your team watching out,
which I think is what you're
talking about here, Joe,
is that we managed to pick that
up and then tell you about it,
which is a great
way to make sure
that everybody's
paying attention
to how you're utilizing
and paying for resources.
Again, thank you so
much for the time today.
I hope people are going
to reach out to you.
You've got a lot
to share, and we
appreciate you taking the time.
I'll talk to you soon.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Perfect.
Thanks so much, Bruno.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]